if you are googling about diet
understand that even though it's the
information age I call it the
misinformation age my name is LeeAnn
Weintraub I'm a registered dietician in
Los Angeles my name is Kevin Libby I'm a
nutritionist for ph2 nutrition and I
provide nutrition counseling and
consulting services to adults families
businesses and organizations today we're
gonna be answering Google questions
about diet registered dietitians like
myself are food and nutrition experts
but we're not always big fans of diets
diets often don't work people fail at
diets and then there's this kind of sad
feeling of failure that comes along with
that the word diet in general it's got a
connotation to it that is like you know
people have to do restriction I have my
own saying it's not about restriction
it's about consistency so my approach is
more of a lifestyle approach that
focuses on balance portion control
eating healthy nutrient-dense Whole
Foods if you're following a diet and
you're wondering if you can have a cheat
day the answer is maybe the leaner you
are the bigger cheat you can have that
have you are the more it's bad idea I
actually recommend looking at more like
a splurge meal so a meal once a week
maybe twice where you're kind of looking
forward to that maybe indulging in
something that's a little bit off your
plan
I would say you want to be careful with
that there's benefits to a lot of the
healthy food groups like grains like
dairy products and unless you have a
food allergy or food sensitivity most of
us need these healthy food groups for
the micro nutrients and the macro
nutrients that we need you remove
carbohydrates
you'll deplete glycogen stores your
bodies will be forced and utilize fat
for fuel but you can't under calorie you
don't want to restrict calories too much
you want to think about maybe getting
the right amount for your body which
often involves to portion control and
cutting back the excess in America we've
over stated protein way too much
concentrated proteins will still spike
insulin your body needs a balance of all
the macronutrients the amount of
calories carbohydrates protein and fats
that you need in your daily nutrition
plan really varies from person to person
it's not just protein you have to break
down the tissue by working out really
really hard with really heavy weight but
you also need carbohydrate to fuel the
training and it's not the same for
everybody so you want to focus on a plan
that works for you and speaking with an
expert such as a registered dietician or
if your physician is gonna give you the
best approach and the best advice that
you need to reach your goals so we just
answer the questions about diet so the
most important thing to take away from
this is it's all about making healthy
balanced eating choices that makes sense
for your lifestyle and your body we want
to go organic we want to stay with
refined oils we want to stay away from
GMOs these are really important things
to get the right answer on and we know
that Google doesn't have all the answers
and if you meet with an expert you get
information and advice that's customized
to you don't overthink it you know
people are way too obsessed with it
don't sweat the petty stuff and don't
pet the sweaty stuff
[Music]